okay four people joining us live stream
we are doing another session of language
completeness and correctness consistency
and correct and completeness LCC for
short uh I've been a little scarce
because I've been working very hard on
my science project but this is a meeting
we're having okay let's talk about value
Q right I've never understood this
function right so right so basically
well except for symbols where it's
slightly more clever and so if you do
value of symbol I think it'll check for
an own value that seems useful it's
about the only thing that seems useful
to me everything else just seems like
hopelessly undoable I mean if I say
value Q of F of seven and I have some
condition to evaluate that could take 10
hours to evaluate I mean what am I
supposed to do right so what I am what I
am suggesting which you know could
either be a method option or you know be
the new default but right we what we can
do quickly and correctly is you know
scan the scan the symbols and the
expression and see if any of them have
any you know down values down code etc
yes and so we could say well he
definitely inert yeah exactly
of course it might not be a note in the
container but it's inert in itself right
I think that's useful
um I mean we could have a second
argument value Q of X / common no
definitions and quotes right as opposed
to value for Q which could just be no
own value which could be the default or
it could be that your 1 is the default
your 1 sounds sensible to me right I
mean what it currently does for an on
symbol expression is just it evaluates
it and sees if it changes just bonkers
it's just bonkers right so what we've
got we've got no definitions we've got
and we could have like well actually we
could just have own value any
definitions I'm not sure we need own
value if we might not with any
definitions right and the other one is
like Oh trial evaluation yet these are
not the same part of speech rate
definitions present trial evaluation
tests
I mean honestly definitions Q might be a
better name for this very bizarre
concept
can we find out where this is used in
code I mean I can imagine definition
skew basically just says are there any
definitions defined for anything's in
exper right it's pretty that's pretty
well defined any definitions even if
they're slash semi Dawei and etc
definitions q4 well that's that's yeah
symbol definitions right so so the two
main well I think one of the main uses
of value which is where is to see if you
know write a sort of a flag right so it
checks if something has a if a variable
has an own value and if it does that you
know uses that variable for you know
setting some value and otherwise it uses
some default and and you know either
method is basically going to be right in
our live stream comments that it works
only for down and own values I wonder
about sub values I should suspect it
should work for those but he's coming to
him its failure to work for up values
and that is a good point because the
question and definitions Q if we had
that is does it you know does it define
up values is it is it searching around
above itself so to speak for something
well and and certainly we symbols
definitions present well it would tell
you that right which which the current
the trial evaluation would not because
well I understand but symbol definitions
present I think we need to break that
into two cases one is is there anything
which will affect the value of this on
its own
and then if this thing has up values
what could happen I mean I think it
would also be useful to have a way to
find out what it has up values with
respect to not a queue function that and
the way you find out what it has up
values is by calling up values right I
mean I don't see that as a useful
exercise no but I'm asking given this
expression okay you've got F of G comma
H comma K Khan whatever something oh I
see no no nothing the only thing that
could have up values that would affect
the outside world is the top-level head
correct exactly yeah okay fair enough so
Ethan on our live stream says that that
also that value also does something with
current value right now I was not aware
of that John are you aware of that
I know I didn't know let's find out of
it I don't recall anything about value
at all and didn't expect to be pulled in
this part of discussion at all property
value there's lots of types of values
well property value is is turning into
annotations and it's been cleaned up
significantly and I don't think it's
relevant to this I personally favor a
definitions Q I think value should be
quietly retired I think it's just
utterly obscure Oh Ethan is saying it
doesn't work with current value hey I
see I see I mean there's a system to
find things well but but wait a symbol
definitions present is a completely
different question from
essentially down code present I mean not
the bleed to call it that but that's but
you understand the concept and in other
words and that's what current value is I
mean it's simple definitions present two
plus two has no symbol definitions
present but it will certainly evaluate
to something different it's which is why
I was not thinking definitions should
right so my suggested the redesigned the
value Q is you know it scans for down
values down code in fact I even say this
somewhere in the notes here you know
right so it scans for all of those
things because that's you know some
adding real value that you know users
can't I mean the fact is we can't and
shouldn't distinguish between unless
it's some context game between you know
user defined values and our system
defined either yeah right but the user
has no way of asking does this have down
code I understand but it might be useful
to say does this have non system
functions you know does this have non
system functions question mark non
system functions or symbols that
evaluate because also what about the
case of system symbols do they have how
do they they have do they have a known
value how does that work they have own
code how does that work well some of
them do oh okay
but I mean some of them have own value
some of them have own code okay but they
have one of the other of those they
don't have some magic mechanism
well they might they might have some of
them have a sort of magic own code but
[Music]
no there's a yeah I'm gonna butt in here
in this part of discussion so so so the
own value is part of the symbol struct
so so that's that's pretty fundamental
that the thing etai is referring to is a
is a mechanism for what we call special
symbols where a function is
automatically run the symbol as change a
lot of the dollar symbols are done like
that like dollar min precision for
example okay so hold on so that then
there is a distinction I claim that can
be drawn which I think will be useful
here given that well okay so first
question is hmm okay if we call it
definitions q then what are the cases
that we want we want um basically let's
let's write it down it's basically any
system any any symbols all right
non system symbols contexts yeah it's
possible
so we don't have anything like that but
but maybe okay all right so then anyway
but we could have hey I mean I just
don't see the value in renaming this
thing I really don't think that that's a
lot of work for no real game I mean I
think having that I mean maybe I mean
well well we'll soon have an allowed
contact so maybe once we do that there
will be you know there will be some
value of you know that context excluded
excluded content okay so but I think
just I mean they think the only
so then this would be if we didn't
rename this would be any symbol
definitions then this would be any non
system symbol definitions like goodness
for auto-completion
when it works well what other cases are
there there's also any symbol own values
and that's it do not consider down
values that seems like it could be
useful I have a hard time imagining that
being useful I mean you don't care about
any evaluations it's for oh I'm trying
to check whether the thing is mmm I
don't know maybe that's not useful
alright the question though is value Q
versus definitions Q I would like to see
some use cases of valley Q I mean but I
give me your argument for why I mean is
value Q understood by people or is value
Q utterly obscure I think there are lots
of bug reports about you know the fact
that value Q evaluates things and causes
side effects and okay so listen can we
collect the bug reports correct some use
cases and look at this again I think
we've got two parts here one is to
retire value Q and make a definitions Q
and the other is to keep value queue and
give it a second argument which is these
or a method option but I would slightly
prefer a second argument because I think
it's very important to the operation of
the function okay but let's let's take a
look at the bug reports please well I
mean I I guess what do you want to know
about the bug reports I mean I've looked
I mean the reason I got I want to really
really get some kind of bucketing of
what they are what are people saying is
it all the thing evaluated and had side
effects or is it more confusion about
what the heck it does it's more the
thing evaluates and there are side
effects or it you know behaves strangely
when something is read for tected or oh
gosh let's talk about read protected
what do what do we do in that case well
I mean they think we still answer the
question honestly which is easy enough
to do whether or not it has the read
protected attribute okay as opposed to
just right we can answer the question of
whether it has definitions associated
with it because the function f can you
know we can know whether it has down
values and things but we're not going to
answer nothing beyond that right no
right nor nor do we attempt to right I
mean we don't attempt to like go into
the down valley patton list and go and
try and match it or something do we no I
mean right now like I said right now all
it does is that if it's not if the in
first argument is not a symbol all it
does is evaluate the first argument and
see if it's different from horrifying
that's just unbelievably horrifying just
looked in all these you know all the
internal uses I've looked at so far the
users we make a value queue all soon to
be targeted completely at symbols no I
didn't think it worked for a few other
them symbols it's okay
go ahead yeah there I
recently came across and I wish I'd
written it down because I can't remember
exactly what it was but it recently came
across one internal use of it for okay
all right so listen listen the the
likely outcome is going to be a bunch of
second arguments the default becoming is
there are their definitions on the thing
right rather than what does it do if you
were to evaluate it yep and that will be
completely equivalent well what about a
colon equals own value with /semi well
it would snow report true I know it will
report true in this circumstance but
does it report true right now yes yes
okay does the own value list is not the
empty list okay okay fine okay well
because that's probably wrong anyway
because the trial evaluation might give
something different because it might say
if it's in the morning the /semi might
be you know depend on time somehow okay
so I don't think that's okay fine all
right we got a direction for this think
so okay let's move on to item two the
shrink wrapping of 3d graphics a pet
peeve a serious pet peeve okay that has
an absurd amount of white space which is
I find kind of amusing given that you've
insisted more and more padding in 2d
plots but that you need somehow in 3d
plots wait a minute wait a minute when
did I talk about more padding in 2d
plots certainly you did a couple years
ago well but padding within the frame
right having things not collide with the
frame okay this is crazy
so it's just stupid I mean so let's just
we just need to figure out what to do
right so your proposal after each I put
this agenda together it was spherical
region goes to none yeah
I think we should change the default
because I think this default is nuts I
don't think anybody you know you don't
see a box there isn't a box box where's
the box the fact that this had a box
around it it's just like well you know
it's kind of like I don't know why does
it remind me of them I should collect
these things for just for some reason
I'm reminded of this incredibly campy
weird old movie called Dark Star I think
a George Lucas production about these
people who went around and blew up
planets that might become unstable in
order to prevent people from settling on
them okay that was an irrelevant and
this is a it might have a box so let's
give it tons of space right well but you
might rotate it great that's a different
issue
that's the spherical region issue and
personally I'm perfectly happy look yes
I think you might very well rotate it
but I think that you know the default
action ok let's talk about when I mean
it is possible that spherical region
should become automatic and should be a
little bit more sophisticated just like
we know that a graphic size under image
size actions changes depending on
whether it's on a list in a list or not
right it's possible that for example if
this thing finds itself in a manipulate
that it should default the spherical
region to true I don't know but you know
in the general usage you do not want all
the stupid empty space well I would
worry a bit about changing the default
and what downstream effects but maybe
John and Brett have more informed
opinions about whether it's at my what's
happening right now is just stupid well
it's just stupid in this one case no I
don't know of any case where it isn't I
mean it's you know in the case where you
aren't drawing the box yeah it's the
surgery of the box it's all good yeah
yeah yeah the box is fine once you have
the box you leave room for the box I'm
good with that when you don't draw the
box you shouldn't leave the space
and particularly not in Graff 3d which
doesn't you know have a box by default I
mean that's the really weird case okay
because most things do have boxes by
default you know graphics 3d has a box
by default I think if you get rid of the
Box a spherical region are automatic
should get rid of the space as well okay
let's talk about the different cut also
point out rotation was mentioned but
we're already dealing I mean you can
even see it in a subtle way with this
issue with rotation it does potentially
change size on rotation and there are
cases where there's a much more dramatic
change inside okay okay so I agree if it
has a long aspect issue okay so there's
room for rotation okay that's one let me
just to make sure everyone understands
what happens on rotation I just threw a
simple thing in chat that you can copy
and paste and see how I understand oh
for goodness sake okay John we have a
beep here we have a beep open the Edit
menu
okay so it it doesn't know that there's
something on the clipboard okay so let's
see so let me recopy this from here okay
very carefully I'm gonna come on see
okay now let me check that's another
application knows that it's on the cut
board okay so I'm gonna paste it into
email and it happily knows that it's on
the clipboard okay
so let's go over here ah paste it this
time I wonder whether the pasting into
another application changed something
it's possible I mean sometimes I have to
do that to get it to work recently the
front end yeah I think and the other
thing is changing window focus by the
way John this this crazy thing with my
machine which might be you know my
machine just had its operating system
reinstalled I'm not at all convinced
that what you were seeing is is the the
the the level of craziness is far beyond
anything anyone has ever reported well I
agree I agree but it's new but it might
be new because I have a new machine yeah
um I also noted that I really had really
huge things on the clipboard and that
seemed to potentially be related but
let's find out what happens over the
next few days okay okay a big long bar
and and just to make it clear click on
the graphics so we can see its bounce
and and see and see how it changed on
you personally I think the behavior we
have right now is beautiful when the
mouse is held down the thing leaves
enough space for itself once well let's
let's start in that state okay now I
hold the mouse down and I start moving
this is beautiful what it does right now
is absolutely magnificent
right and I only raise us because we
were talking about quote leaving enough
room for rotation I just want to make it
clear that we already deal with you know
make up I think it's great I think what
we do right now is great I think the
only mistake here is leaving room for
the stupid box when there isn't a box
now the spherical region
would leave in this case full room for
rotation and I think that's a red
herring from the main issue here I mean
so that leaves room for rotation natural
little rotation right now in the case
where we are the spherical region thing
is independent of boxiness
by the way I think there's something
wrong with the motion controller but the
rotation controller here I just want to
make that comment I think things are
backward rotating when I look if I move
this steadily this way
okay well let's let's say I try to twist
this over okay say I try to rotate it so
see the other side of it okay you to
tell me how to do that
I want to twist this to see the other
side of the bar as usually and if if you
hit for example like right right in the
middle and jagged it to the middle to
the left see no I'm still rotating there
I mean if I hit exactly the center of
mass I'm gonna I'm gonna twist it right
yeah okay so explain that to me because
I don't think this is the right behavior
is there some region where it where it
will do a different thing in the 3d
space
so we're for the spherical region is
where it has nothing to do with
spherical region this issue has to do
with rotation control it doesn't have
anything to do with spherical region
does it I'll do the same thing without
spherical region
okay I can tell you a way to do it more
successful when reef spherical region is
not on but I don't know look at this
thing look at this thing this thing is
let's see if I can okay my exercise is
to see the other side of his bar okay I
finally got it because I managed to
because by pulling the mouse left
I wasn't rotating now I mean we worked
on this several years ago the rotation
controller the question of how the
rotation controller works I mean
presumably you can draw a vector field
here and you can label the arrows of the
vector field with what it's going to do
in 3d space true or not true sure okay
what does the vector field look like
that is each arrow at each point at each
base point and each Mouse Direction
there is an implication for a rotation
in 3d by the way I should say that's
assuming that you are dragging in a
straight line I think because there's a
point when you get far enough out when
you can kind of move around the image
and it rotates it rotates the image well
one would think maybe it should be in
the plate of the screen it's not quite
the plane of the screen so if I had a
gamepad hooked up it would do something
different true it would actually have
more degrees of freedom remember if it's
more degrees or not it should be you see
do you know I mean I've been doing a
bunch of stuff 3d objects I'm about to
hook up a gamepad to my computer so am I
going to be happy
I think it depends on the the rotation
method you specified the current so so
so if you like plot 3d correct me if I'm
wrong YouTube but I believe plot has a
different rotation methods right because
it tends to not flip itself upside down
yeah okay but to be honest it's been a
while since any of us have looked at the
at the USB controller mechanism well
fine I'm not as concerned about that I'm
concerned about the default here and the
truth is I mean you know fancy animation
programs bring up this whole very hard
to understand sphere with lines and the
stab the other when you rotate we don't
need that but it will be useful or maybe
we need it if you hold down a key or
something I mean this is exactly where
you know the the toolbar that is
supposed to get attached to 3d graphics
which I imagine is in Noah's path to
work on um could be useful by
potentially having some tabbing
mechanism where you can tab it into
different rotation controls comments
yeah we haven't spent much time thinking
about that but yes potentially right I
mean the fact is what we need to do
there is it's an exercise given the
shape I want to see you know just paint
numbers on it and I want to see how long
it takes you to get that number to the
front you see what I'm saying and I
think that's a good way of understanding
whether we have a rotation controller
that people understand can you try it
with one one one cube instead I'm
wondering if there's a scaling issue
because of the aspect ratio that
yeah I have a much easier time with
things like this this is much more
natural I mean if I'd make it even a
three you know the problem is that I
keep on hitting okay so I go to this
case here and the problem is ok so right
now yeah yeah okay I can I can believe I
know YouTube and I have looked at code
that deals with you know tries to deal
with some issues for things with extreme
aspect ratios and I can believe that
there may be some you know I think I
think we're looking at a began here
because I think what's happening is as
brett has surmised what's happening is
so long as so an you zoom maybe you can
comment on is there a discontinuous
thing so right here as I move it but by
the way whenever it tumbles it's wrong
right if I move continuously the thing
better not tumble in the making sense
yeah okay so here I'm gonna try to
rotate the middle okay so first of all
there was a bit of discontinuous
tumbling there and now we're not even
rotating anymore for reasons I don't
understand why aren't we rotating
anymore my mouse is out to the right
well I don't be rotating anymore because
you're in a different mode and this is
let's let's do this with something that
is closer to working let's take the unit
cube there and and now now dragged out
to the side
I hit when I'm outside the bankbook now
move in a circle around oh my god Sarris
know what I mean is a circle all the way
around the graphic oh I think the
graphic but right now I go in a circle
it's nodding its head well it well disk
because you're not doing what I intended
you to do I know because I understand
the horizontal
I got it that circle all the way around
the graphic does some kind of fairly
somewhat useful yeah thing but over here
the horizontal motion is irrelevant it's
ignoring the horizontal motion that's
right once you've hit a certain extent
then then you've basically switched into
a different rotation controller yeah but
why didn't the icon change well I think
because we've never thought about trying
to communicate right well I mean so if
Steven puts his cursor at the top right
corner of the graphic oh yeah what's
that yeah that's that's now the just the
circle mode and nothing else well that's
nice but but then over here is a mode of
unknown moodiness I mean what is that
mode is that the circle motor is that
some other that it's a circle mode as
long as you stay outside of the circle
if you move back in then it doesn't
change processes yeah yeah I think it's
just the wrong person oh yeah okay so
we've got two issues here one is we've
got the long bar issue of just how much
of the middle of the bar is XY plane
rotation right and that seems to be
reasonable for these things that are
fairly spherical but it thinks seems to
be fairly unreasonable for these things
that are deeply you know whatever
prolate or something right so can we
figure out how to fix that used to I
think that's whew yeah please try to
figure out what's going on okay
meanwhile I propose that the the only
thing we need I claim is getting rid of
the stupid room for the box so we didn't
have we didn't have the space for the
box everything will be great
so I'm hesitant to do that in 12-1 but I
I would like to you know have enough
time to make sure that we're not
making a huge mistake that will take
some time to you know work its way to
the surface
but in principle I'm not gonna disagree
with you well let's put spherical region
heroine on make it do that
I would like that I would really like
that to be the default for graph 3d I
don't think this issue has come up do we
have Charles in this meeting we asked
Charles I don't I don't think this issue
has come up for graph 3d that's the case
where I'm most passionate about it so to
speak
look I've never seen it be useful in the
case where you don't have a box can we
can we pull Charles and Roger and if
neither of them sees a problem with this
I think we should really try to do it I
mean if you just want graph 3d to you
know add the shrink-wrap right yeah but
I don't want I want that shrink rat to
be packaged in a less absurd way so it
works for right but if but it's not an
exposed option to graph 3d right so
graph 3d could just said that when it's
generating its graphics well I
understand but it could what it could
set is spherical region R or none by
default which is this basically because
we do want to be able to make it have a
spherical region look the fact is okay
is there a spherical region i automatic
right now look this is nothing right now
I think it's true false or a sphere what
do you mean or a sphere oh you mean an
actual sphere I mean you can specify you
know the center and radius
that was what a 12o feature John or was
it 11 Draenor so not documented so
you're telling me that if I go here and
I say so let's take out my cuboid as an
example I say here yeah I was just told
to implement it not to document it funny
okay well I mean it you know in all
seriousness this was let's see I
actually actually it looks like you two
did write up some stuff look at this
weird picture what is it doing well your
your your sphere is centered at 0 0 and
that's where one of the vertices of your
cube is yeah there's nothing wrong with
that at all
magnificent I apologize you actually did
write some documentation for this and it
slipped past my review so I can take
care of that right now yeah I think
you've gotta give me a graphics 3d or
something John but okay okay so this
documentation issue it should not be on
John it should be in Brett's team to
document this please well it's I mean so
sometimes it's you know it's a bit
slippery where it is because Bret's team
was the one that requested it but no it
came out of Jeff I think okay anyway
somebody other than us requested it but
we're the ones that understand the you
know the consequences okay because we
implemented it okay so the Box business
the space for the box question to my
mind it is just a bug if there isn't a
box that shouldn't be spaced for it
period end of story and I think we
should simply fix that bug I don't
really think that okay so because I we
can try that I mean so the question is
if you wanted to leave all right if you
interview if you want to leave space for
a box how would you do it
really what we want is spherical region
somewhat obscurely
aro cube right
I mean it's spherical region aro box is
what it really is and really spherical
region should have been called something
like rotation region or something
well spherical region okay you see what
I'm saying I mean this is yeah I mean
basically you want I mean the in the you
know going further down that slope is
providing you know a dodecahedron or
something or au which there's no reason
we can't do I mean we know where it's
like there is a dodecahedron but you
don't see it but please use it for my
bounding box now reason why you might
care about that is if you've got five
graphics in a row and what you want is
the I mean here's what I would do I mean
if I've got five graphics in a row and I
want them all to agree in terms of
absolute size I would throw them all
into a region Union or something to
define the size what would actually work
there so let's imagine that let's
imagine that spherical region was able
to take graphics primitives as you know
some arbitrary set of graphics
primitives so in particular if you had
it could just take the graphics
primitives and leave enough room for
them leave enough room well okay so
there are two questions leave enough
room for them where they are and leave
enough room for them if rotated see what
I'm saying right
both are interesting I mean I in fact
the leave enough room for where they are
would be useful for 2d graphics as well
because that's an issue of you know of
lining up when you have multiple
graphics in some collection making sure
that they all agree they all have the
same plot range and
right but I mean and so the way to do
that would be to just collect everything
and say here's everything I want to you
know okay so what that really is is it
is things considered for purposes of
deciding the graphic size what is the
graphic size what is that what is the
thing I mean there's plot range padding
but what is the thing that determines is
the supply range padding issue it's
nothing it's closer to image padding
maybe but it's not really that either
but I don't know what you mean by closer
to it's it's not I what what analogy are
you trying to draw I don't understand
literally any of those padding's so what
are you trying to say metaphorically it
is I'm saying that it's closer to image
padding in the sense that image padding
in 2d is padding outside the frame and
this is padding outside or outside the
plot range okay question question in
this padded area nothing will ever draw
true or not true in other words if the
plot range was restricted the size of
the graphic but it extends into this
region is it clipped before it gets to
this region or does it extend into the
region because it can clipped I think
okay yeah so this is in fact genuinely
just padding and I think there are two
cases of padding there is padding that
is in case of rotation and there's
padding just because leaving room for
invisible primitives okay so the two
cases right padding I mean
it's basically padding for invisible
primitives for unrendered primitives
primitives and and things like boxes and
options like boxes or like ticks because
I could have like boxes or ticks because
I could have some great big tick
specification there that has a you know
with a draws a picture of a verb you
know I don't know a tree or something in
my in my tick labels okay so that's one
case there's padding for unrendered
primitives and there's padding for
potential rotations right
okay so let's consider the case of
padding for things boy see if I say I
want padding for boxes but I didn't
specify the boss ratios yet see what I'm
saying
I could I could have a different padding
I mean like like what business is it I
mean this is another bug you know bug
creature here right because this thing
let's see what happens if I say box
ratios arrow 1 2 2 2 1 1 2 3 2 1
whatever
oh boy that's wild is that really what
we want that's just crazy right remember
we should get Charles here that this
this seems crazy what just happened here
somebody looked for Charles please at
least earlier this morning he was
unavailable
okay well there it is with a box Hey and
and just so you know I'm throwing in a
chat the way to actually show this fully
shrink-wrapped this one here the
original example but but you can extend
it to you know anything you want using
the same method yeah oh I got a beep
failure I got a beep perlier don't I
have it in the agenda I think I had I
have another anything you want me to
look at John I I know what I need to
know as much as I can debug it look now
let's just see if if changing the focus
changes it oh it did
changing the window focus changed it as
well John okay well that will be a nice
bug to nail ok beautiful magnificent
exactly what we want and we rotate it
and it leaves run and we're just golden
exactly the right behavior that is
documented by the way it did the math
adoption
ok fine but it's totally obscure and
it's the wrong default I mean all method
options are obscure but yes ok now will
we have the shrink-wrap and we had boxed
but what does the shrink wrap thing do
okay actually I'm not a hundred percent
certain how shrink wrap interacts with
spherical region it's possible that it
might do the wrong thing with spherical
region I just haven't tried it let's try
this
you wanna make box false again no I'm
happy to okay so that's fine well except
it's clipping from time to time and I
thought that's what spherical region
said it shouldn't do it should never get
into that clipping state you know and
that's what I'm stipulating is there
might be that kind of issue okay well I
mean I prefer to have that issue than to
have all these graphics be the wrong
size right I mean if we repeat that will
with just box goes to false right then
presumably we won't get any clipping
unless we get clipping on the actual
promos themselves hopefully not we got a
little bit of clipping nah I don't think
this was the worst case for this wait a
minute vertical regions are true
shouldn't that leave the space for the
thing well and and I I think I don't
know a future knows the soft-top who
said but I think the shrink wrapping
method might just be kind of blowing
through the spherical region code okay
this is crazy
right what just happened here is just
bonkers bonkers bonkers bonkers why why
is it leaving room for the box when
there isn't a box it doesn't need the
room for that to get a spherical region
for the objects showing does not need
room for the box he was trying to so
it's obviously wrong I'm sorry it's just
obviously wrong
go ahead well it's consistent with the
current behavior of box goes to faults
right so it's just wrong the behavior of
box goes to false the question of
whether there is a virtual box is an
independent question from whether
spherical region is true i Steven though
it may be quite difficult to computes
what it is I mean if you think about it
with the box we just have to compute six
planes and there you go but
what you're suggesting is well it would
be quite a lot of convex hull yeah you
have to compute the convex hull but we
have pretty efficient code to compute
the convex hull of things these days
well in the kernel yeah well why don't
we do one if we send along a spherical
region to true we could send along a
convex hull send along convex hull beta
because we can't change the vertical
region so our region to true is a kernel
with you what do you mean well are you
saying that purely in the notebook you
can change the vertical region to true
and change the behavior without ever
doing yes I mean it's a graphic 3d box
setting it's it's it's not common for
people to do it but it's absolutely
possible well then do a kernel roundtrip
if they change it in that pick in the
obscure case of box dis false I mean
it's better to do the right thing than
to not do the right thing that do the
right thing and and have a kernel
roundtrip than to not do the right thing
all right let's let's unpack a little
bit what we've said here okay first
point the behavior of leaving room for a
VirtualBox when there isn't a box is
crazy and we should just get rid of it
particularly for cases where by default
there isn't a box but I think we should
get rid of it in all cases when there
isn't a box so the only question is when
we leave room for a virtual box so to
speak and the general case of that is we
leave room for virtual lots of stuff in
fact what we end up with is essentially
a region defining graphic independent of
the graphic itself am I making sense so
the region defining graphic could be a
graphics 3d with boxed and etc etc or it
could be either overlay options to the
just in graphic or it could be its own
primitives does that make sense
I'm sorry okay so what I'm saying is
there is a graphic there is a ghost
graphic that defines what space should
be left okay that ghost graphic could be
bigger than this graphic it could be
smaller than this graphic in other words
imagine that what I really want to see
is is the spherical region right in the
center of this graphic I don't want to
see anything else I'm perfectly happy to
have my zoom level by default be that
but in other words I could define a
shadow graphic essentially that defines
the the drawing region for this graphic
did that make sense to people
and that shadow graphic could for
example be this graphic with boxed on or
something else are you getting what I'm
saying I mean that's the general case I
think yes no John it I other people this
make some sense
I think it makes sense as I understand
it I mean I don't know that I can
necessarily foresee what the
consequences might be okay well let me
put that's if we did this if we said
leave enough space and other question is
where are you leaving the spaces you
know there are multiple places to leave
space there's inside the frame that's
outside the frame you know it's
basically image padding and plot range
padding right and it's not totally
obvious which of those you I mean for
example in the case where I've got this
okay let's take a look at this guy okay
let's look at this piece of lunacy
let's see if I say frame arrow true it's
not an option for 3d I see but and if I
were to say frame duh it would just go
outside the bounding box right even you
would be wrapping framed around your
show and so yeah so it's not it's not
it's not doing anything notable with
respect to this it that that framed is
then taking into account image padding
correct that frame is taking into
account the entirety of the graphics 3d
box okay so if I do this very
impressively the framed responds
accordingly beautiful sure yeah
magnificent I would argue that I mean I
might want a little bit more padding
here if I did want more padding what
would I do i would say image padding
padding goes to ten yeah my dinner hour
for sure what the what the unit so does
that in didn't do what I expect should
not work it were its frame margins frame
margins this is oh I'm sorry I thought
you were passing it to framed
sorry I'm passing it to the graphic I
want to say aren't you being mutually
contradictory saying you want the
shrink-wrap and adding padding no I
don't think so I think I would that's
the whole point I think shrink wrap is
the wrong option okay I think shrink
wrap listen the the main issue is am i
leaving okay so there are two things I
could leave room for other graphics
primitives like boxed or speculative
rotation that makes sense I mean I could
imagine in speculative other things
other than rotation but let's just stick
with rotation for now I mean for example
here's an example let's say that I have
a you know a graphic that contains a tab
view and the tab view has different
sizes I could leave room for speculative
opening of the tab view but by that
point it's hopeless it's like value cue
you know to know what could possibly
happen is a hopeless task okay so by the
way does tabbed you have a way of equal
sizing doesn't it doesn't don't those
yeah image size all okay okay
the downside is that it's much more
expensive you have to travel
exactly and if each if some of those
things have dynamics you have to resolve
all the dynamics mm-hmm and it only
works at the time well I don't even want
to know when it when it determines the
answer I mean in other words the thing
you're looking at it determines the
answer before displays a view which
means if yet if you're loading a
notebook you might be twiddling your
thumbs if that's expensive
well but also it could be the case that
the the tab that you are currently
looking at is should be resized because
of a change in another tab yes and that
would happen Wow okay cool if crazy
everything's broken about our product
a lot of great stuff okay
all right so let's come back to this all
right the two cases the yeah I I don't
know what the interaction of image
padding here should have been I think
image margins I don't know if you tried
that I think image margins should work
what's the team image margins an image
padding well so I'm frankly unclear in
the 2d case rather entry what happened
here well it's the scaled thing you
should have used scaled just use the
defaults as points just like do ten or
something there and you know whatever 30
okay but I'm still I'm clipping against
that um yes that's that's wrong but
that's because yeah that should be
adding outside it looks like it's
pushing inside the graphic and that's
maybe it has to do with the shrink wrap
I don't know yeah all right okay I'm
sorry
let's come back out to the main main
point here okay two things leave room
for primitives and leave room for
speculative rotation okay yeah it's so
just by the way something that might be
easier than doing you know a convex Hall
and pass that around we might be able
I'd have to talk to you two about this
offline but we might be able to do this
fairly efficiently in the front end if
it's not a perfect convex hull but if we
do something like you know I mean right
now we're doing essentially a cube if we
did something like an icosahedron
instead we oh I mean so what you're
basically suggesting is you just take
the coordinate bounds with respect to
particular orientation yes yes we're
already doing that but only with six
orientations you know if we decide to do
it with say 20 yeah yeah that might be
sufficient right yeah I mean we want
well I mean okay yeah we basically just
need bounding planes it doesn't
necessarily have to be a regular
polyhedron actually we just you're just
suggesting more bounding planes and
nobody would know the difference right I
mean you know if you pulled out your
magnifying glass you'd definitely be
able to tell in certain cases but I I
think we're looking you know for a close
enough is close enough it could be
parametrized with a method option if we
had to and that's also go ahead well I
was also going to point out that it's
not as if you know convex hull will
necessarily get it you know perfectly
right pixel perfect if it's a
sufficiently complicated graphics and it
also has all kinds of weird tentacles in
it like specially rendered you know
right like if you stuck in the lower
dimensional region at might you know it
might miss it or something well I'm not
sure about that but but okay okay fine I
like John's suggestion there okay so we
think we can deal with speculative
rotation okay
let's deal with the primitives question
okay so my claim is that there are two
kinds of things one could do one is
graphics primitives the other is options
unfortunately the options might depend
on I mean the thing that is guaranteed
to work is you just give it a graphic
and you say leave room for this graphic
do you see what I'm saying
usually we just to give a positive zero
for that then put it in together in the
list fine but we're not going to ask our
users to have that hack right but if
it's a simple implementation if it's a
simple specification then you know we
could automate that right I mean if
basically what it is is you just ghost
it right that's what that's saying but
it's got to be a full ghosting nothing
nothing nothing pokes out of you know
there's no paranormal weirdness here
I think there's no opacity that's inside
the ghosted thing that somehow do
pacifies the opacity zero yeah um okay
well let's look at what that would look
like okay so then then what that would
be is something like what would should
it be called plot range pack graphics
region or something is defined by that
graphic and then what we could do is we
could have a shorthand there that says
things like you know something like
boxed arrow true in other words graphics
region could take either a graphics
object or some naked options I think
actually we want to call it something
less I mean something like graphics
rendering region or something or
rendering region maybe doesn't want to
be called region most certainly is
property of the renderer that we're
talking about can we avoid using region
because region is is used for other
things what else could we call this
volume and that mean that's used for
other things too I had the same complain
it's not necessarily volume we want to
do it in 2d as well want to do the exact
same thing in 2d okay what are the
family of other things related to it
it's things like image padding I mean
mostly things with padding or margin in
the name I mean but it's related to you
know even just plain plot range isn't it
a plot rendering region would probably
be fairly unambiguous what rendering
region could take a so that would be
away
I don't know precisely its interaction
with image padding and plot range
padding that has to be thought about but
plot rendering region would be a leave
room for this thing right so there are
three possibilities it could be graphics
paratus I mean it could be it could be a
full graphics object you know in the
Youssou opacity zero hack anything that
works for that together with naked
options together with what are we saying
together with possibly an absolute
coordinate bounds thing okay so question
here so the default value of plot
rendering region would be automatic or
or would it be inherited no no no no
don't don't don't ask us to use a
narrative this right-hand side that has
that has implications you're not
thinking about okay all right fine so
out of curiosity what does plot region
do as an option that I never use
frankly frankly it's not something that
I you know it's in my head for about
five minutes anytime I really need it
and that and then it dumps out it how
can how can the examples here not even
mentioned plot region office or even the
best state plot region does this I think
no plot region okay so this is an
outside-the-box thing right well what
happens okay because this if there's a
box yeah this is this is actually what
we're talking about isn't it well it can
be inside or outside the box depending
on what I mean it can it doesn't have to
include the entire boxes but I know no I
understand it I understand it but it's
saying exactly what we're talking about
here this is our plot rendering region
which we already called plot region and
all we're suggesting here go ahead sorry
why is it taking 2d coordinates it's
like taking the zero one scaled things
or something yeah yeah that's exactly
what it's doing
I mean this is an option that was it was
built for the 2d world and then kind of
applied retroactively Leon to 3d as if
it were 2d
it has a pathetic set of examples
absolutely pathetic probably because no
one's looked at it since v6 yeah
and it's older than most of our
employees and frankly it's I don't think
let me confirm but I don't think it's a
huge source of bugs which is usually an
indication that either the nobody uses
it
yeah either people aren't using it or
they've given up on its I mean I suspect
that the general padding options that we
have these days provide better controls
that are easier to understand and easier
to work with and plot region yeah we've
got three bugs on this and the last
update on any of them was over five
years ago that reset when ice when I say
update update might include that huee
said still reproducible or something
like that but this plot region is very
closely related to this plot rendering
region thing that we just invented the
region and scaled coordinates that the
plot should fill in the final display
area boy that's confusing well I mean
it's if you think of it purely as a 2d
problem it's not that confusing okay so
if we were to introduce plot rendering
region maybe we retire plot region
Sandara our livestream is pointing out
something which he says is horrifying
but let's see what it is by the way this
thing here with the box ratios I just
think is bonkers and did we manage to
find Charles no okay somebody asked him
about this because it just seems
completely bonkers to me else understand
what the heck is that
what did it just do help first of all
why did it to burp like that what did
you do well I put a plot range in there
what on earth is it doing I might see oh
I'm seeing the inner struts that's just
the very inside struts the problem is
that the center of rotation is not where
I think it is do you see what I'm saying
that plot range 20 should make well the
center of rotation isn't necessarily the
center of rotation of this object and
I'm sure if I say plot range to 200 I'll
see them what is going on well what's
the plot range on the underlying graph
wait wait wait wait how could plot range
of 200 have made that kind of blastula
thing well what's clearly pot range is
causing you to zoom in I don't know why
it is but can you get rid of shrink wrap
yeah that's pretty interesting object
that we see there I suspect that it's
doing some you know calculation based on
the plot range like determining the
radii of the spheres and tubes and then
shrink-wrap is
drastically changing the scale okay good
buck Thank You sander very very weird
bug okay so that's a nasty interaction
between shrink-wrap and plot range can
you move the plot range inside the graph
I don't know if it'll change anything or
not I'm just no just a different angle
on the blastula it's pretty cool shape
it is it's a creature it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna replicate eventually
it's going to turn into a fine lizard or
something okay um well that's just a bug
all right let's let's just review the
comments that have come in on our
livestream and then then I want to come
and come and make this a conclusion yeah
that is that is a shrink wrap thing by
the way if you pull out shrink wrap it
doesn't do that okay and yeah I suspect
it has to do with shrink wrap you know
zooming in on something which is you
know kind of less and less granular in
terms of the computed sizes of the tubes
and spheres and such that's that's my
guess um Ethan is commenting on our live
stream wouldn't it be nice to work photo
show how to connect controllers to
graphic 3d we have had that for 15 years
haven't we I was wrong by a few years
it's only 13 years yeah what would we
look at here no controller in linking
gamepad and device interface connecting
to external devices that's kind of lame
we should have a workflow on this on the
gamepad thing that is a good suggestion
but we have which by which by the way
and this is click on connect to external
devices guide so it should be noted that
until 12:00 1:00 this has always just
worked by default that all you have to
do is plug in the controller and select
until they get broken the well what
happened was yeah I mean I mean there
were two things first of all first of
all we frequently got reports from users
saying what the heck you know my you
know my thing is consuming CPU or
graphics just started moving or
something like that it's because they
had a controller plugged in they didn't
even know about that was issue number
one issue number two and the one that
really kicked us into motion on this was
Catalina Catalina basically said if you
are going to ask about this preemptively
then we are going to force you to throw
up scary permissions requests for the
user and we were doing that like it's
startup and that was not accept okay so
what are we doing now so now so we
changed the default values of the
options to control this so they're off
by default but you can still turn them
on I see that's not silly
but does this say what to do here I have
not I didn't even think to update the
workflows so I've updated the you know
various functional home pages but yeah I
guess are gonna need to be updated okay
yes then the same thing is true for
manipulates as well as 3d graphics we've
made the similar changes in both areas
okay
there is there is however a thing called
a controller manipulate and since if
you're using controller manipulate you
really wanted to use controllers
everything is on for that fine
let's make sure that this is reported in
the in the release notes uh yeah sure
Emily also should do the workflow thing
so my question here I mean I was trying
to get this VR setup to work for my
physics project stuff and what I really
want it's kind of the Ironman interface
where I can because I'm dealing with
these crazy 3d graph things and you know
I guess Charles was gonna try and write
a thing that actually does spring
electrical embedding where you can pick
up a piece of the graph and move it in
VR so to speak but the problem with that
is how do you how do you you know what
is the you know how do you control that
what do you do I mean the best thing
would be you know some hand you know
leap motion II type thing leap motion
just got bought by somebody who bought
it Facebook of somebody I don't remember
who bought it i doesn't sound promising
for its future
um but is there a way to do that with
anything we have right now if I wanted
to do that if I wanted to do a
controller where I can sense my position
relative to something in VR I guess
that's more something to be done on the
unity side Isis yeah yeah everything I'm
aware of is in unity we've we've been
playing a little bit with some AR stuff
in the iOS front end but we haven't we
haven't done a any serious VR and the
last welfare a number of years in the
desktop front of the sleeping that's
unity right well I mean listen we got
burnt in the early 90s yeah um and look
I finally have a use case we'll see
whether it actually works out I finally
have a real use case where we can where
were you know uploading flexible 3d 3d
graphs that are manipulable and what I
want is to stick them in a kind of a
warehouse in VR yeah no no no that said
I mean you know I think I think most of
what's been done in what we've done in
unity so far hasn't involved this kind
interactive manipulation that you want
to do I'm we have to have a specific
unity app which takes our assets and
does that with them yes and I'm sure
it's possible but I know that Kyle's
trying to work on that anyway okay let's
go back to the livestream questions will
graphics 3d have a toolbar not in 12-1
sadly hopefully in 12 - yes pinch-zoom
still doesn't work yeah that's on the
roadmap - now that we've got full
support for all the 64-bit stuff we
should be able to do this it's yes it
was it was cocoa you know rewriting
everything - cocoa was the big I mean
which also was part of the 64-bit
project but yes and another gestures I
mean one could imagine for example this
rotation yes whole thing yes I mean
gestures throughout the front-end not
not just in 3d graphics but in
particular rotation control could be
done with gestures except nobody will
ever learn them I mean like one of the
simplest and most annoying ones to me is
you know being able to use the you know
the typical two fingers swipe back
gesture to you know go back and help you
er and we couldn't even get that but in
principle we should now be able to okay
um show books yes no invisible that's a
reasonable suggestion box Tarot
true/false that's a good suggestion to
deal with the boxed case
that's an interesting suggestion
true/false and invisible that's a good
suggestion I mean that would deal with
that I mean I think we want a more
general solution but that would
certainly deal with wow that's an old
thing
Wow hasn't been touched since then wowie
look at that um I like that suggestion
box taro invisible um we could just call
it transparent right which is a symbol
that we have which might be clearer
doesn't transparent evaluate to the does
evaluate yeah that's a I don't like that
because of that value AIT's to opacity
of zero no now I know invisible is also
a symbol that we have but it's actually
a function what does it do oh it's
invisible for it makes things invisible
yes it's a typesetting generator right
which is in fact what we would want to
do I mean the other possibility is that
we support that in graphics and make
invisible be the equivalent of opacity
zero in graphics it wouldn't be
difficult to support and graphics would
be pretty straightforward I think
this is just gonna pink box isn't it
yeah yes but we could make it typeset -
you know something that just like you
know sets all the options - opacity zero
that seems useful I think
okay so let's zoom out again from that
all right I think we should fix the
connection between boxed and spherical
region should simply be removed if there
isn't a box
don't leave space for it unless perhaps
we have boxed arrow invisible okay
you don't think boxes oh you you haven't
been I mentioned the invisible being a
function because you haven't been crazy
about using function names as I don't
want to lose function names yes but I
mean boxed do you think box Tarot
automatic makes any sense I don't think
so no I don't think so I don't have a
concrete alternative to suggest we could
have false mean the same thing it has
always meant and used none for the yes
that's that's reasonable yeah
for the case of for the case of leaving
the space I was suggesting the opposite
false means that false means don't throw
it none means the Box shouldn't exist in
any way whatsoever I don't particularly
like that because people use box to
false all the time - I think the case
that of leaving the mysterious space for
the box is really obscure I'm not gonna
argue with that okay all right so listen
let's go ahead box taro in quotes
invisible and let's try and support the
invisible wrapper but that's lower
parity and let us look at the
possibility of a plot rendering region
but we need to understand how there
interacts with every other piece of
weird padding we have out
okay I mean the plot rendering region
thing might help with the long term
issue of how do you line up you know
comparable graphics you know in an array
okay were there any other loose loose
ends here and then the other thing was
just you know trying to do the instead
of the rendering you know the six planes
using more planes to figure out the
exactly actually this idea yeah very
good idea um okay
as a suggestion here about 3d rotation
controllers from things like blender we
certainly looked at those back when we
designed the current 3d rotation
controller it's a complicated area it
might be worth seeing whether there are
some new things that have evolved in
that area um okay and meanwhile that
weird bug with the shrink wrapping okay
so we're not we're going to do don't
leave space for the box which is
equivalent to the shrink wrapping we
don't need the shrink wrapping now we
just we're just not leaving space for
the box correct
Youssou and everybody i am not a hundred
percent certain if those two
propositions are totally equivalent but
we can figure that out let's figure that
out ASAP okay all right we've got a good
solution here all right I think we we we
had other things on our agenda for today
I think we're already over time although
I would like to just bring up this is so
we got a bunch of people here for this
yeah but I think we just have to push
this off the neck right I mean this is
interesting but okay I want to bring up
blacklisted contexts for a minute
because I'm seeing yet more weird
context show up and I want to understand
our procedure here I mean like whatever
that is shouldn't be there so my
question is how do we find out what
these are and how do we hunt them down
and get rid of them well right the only
way to find out what they are is to do a
good code search for the context and
right
data comes from stats right I was going
to say if you just look at the symbols
that defines it's clearly some sort of
stats utility context okay fine but but
okay my question is this within the code
base we can either automatically search
the code base we can try and pick it up
in QA tests we can try to figure out
what's been documented because if it
hasn't been documented ever you know
okay so to me there are several
different things we could scan the
documentation for all contexts that are
mentioned right those are white listed
right we can then scan the code base for
contexts that it mentions those are by
default blacklisted does anybody have a
better suggestion I mean at least for
some of the ones I think you could get a
lot of the context to blacklist as a
side effect of when the MX files are
built for the colonel fine that's a good
place to get it but look so we've got
things which are definitely white listed
which is things mentioned in
documentation things which are
definitely blacklisted like the MX files
building stuff probably they're all
blacklisted probably probably unless
they are documented yes except for the
ones that are white listed right okay
and then I would recommend scanning the
rest of the code base plus I would
recommend that we have you know we keep
something when the QA tests are run
every time you know as a bunch of
testing been done we see what contexts
were created and the laws become if
they're not documented they well of
course there could be ones that are
created as part of testing the contact
system but who do we think is
responsible for a project management
point of view for dealing with this
blacklisting stuff
well the blacklist thing I mean the
actual implementation side of
blacklisting is done by Tom Sherlock so
that would be in part in terms of
finding the things to be blacklisted
that's not something that's ever been
really discussed and
we have certain patterns so like you
know dump like alright okay Tom don't
private is automatically blacklisted and
okay listen it needs to be one of the
one of the PM's who's dealing with core
system stuff so I don't know um who is
is Devon was Devon PM in this meeting
yes yeah I'm here okay so I think it's
up to you to figure out it's either you
or it's somebody that you find and I
mean this should come to the next
release meeting sure okay um Steven I
would like to propose that you know we
don't delve into this quite yet just
because we're working on a on this
problem in the related context for save
definitions okay we should okay well
those should be merged but I mean we we
do need to this inventory of things and
we could certainly improve on what we
have right now incrementally by the way
suggestion on the live stream about
bookmarking viewpoints yeah we've talked
about I mean they're two things we've
talked about for a long time one is
standard camera you know like like when
you you know when people make movies and
things they have these crazy you know
cameras mounted on these what are those
things called those arms that go up and
down and somebody sits at the but I
don't remember what those things are
called but Tim you know they're these
standard motions some of which got
invented by some particular
cinematographer for some particular
movie um and you know there's standard
motions of sweeping around a graphic and
things and we've long intended Brett
maybe you can comment on this we've long
intended to support a bunch of those
sweeping kinds of things and I suppose
now that we have video support that
becomes more realistic comment I think
definitely it'll come up yo you know
uncle more you know necessary with the
video stuff so by the way I'll just
point out that we have a rudimentary
form of this in the 3d image toolbar
okay what does it do I mean it's it's
it's not you know Millar jumber of
options but it has kind of you know the
obvious ones random image random image
well I was 3d can I do a 3d image yeah
yeah rent random image of one list of
five five five okay where's my toolbar
that's my toolbar it's the it's the next
to the right next to the I yeah not yeah
few options so I mean you know what
we're looking at here isn't yeah that's
that's that's it's it's yeah it's not in
motion and it's not kind of you know
maybe some of the more interesting stuff
but it's a starting point no I agree I
think the one in motion I don't even
know I mean if that's something we could
imagine John is that something we could
imagine as a front-end thing that we
have something Oh absolute line sure
yeah so it's a few basically but but
however what we have I mean if you're
gonna have a motion then I mean one of
the you know structures involved in that
is you know defining you know something
that looks like a path and we have some
constructs for a bit like paths but
we've been kind of knocking around the
notion of you know defining a proper
path you know structure for a long time
without how about what do you mean it
wasn't just the line or it's a line in
basis you know you don't usually want a
straight line no I understand but it's a
line in some cone it's you know it's I
mean one could imagine you know like you
know and interpolating you know what it
is let's be clear it's elements of so3
actually more than just so3 it's more
than elements of the rotation group
because it has zooming and things as
well so you're actually making a line in
yeah well yes they're the
there's also facing and there's also I
mean what we would refer to as the
angular view what you just called
zooming right right but let me so the
fact is that there are many bizarre
coordinate systems one can imagine in
these groups which we haven't even
parameterised we parameterize some
coordinate systems for graphics but
that's different from prioritizing them
in the rotation group yeah but by the
way someone on the livestream Andre on
the live stream says they are called
giraffes by which he probably means
those things that make cameras go up and
down that's a good name for them the in
any case
yeah it's a good it's a good name which
we could use somehow in our system
because it will not conflict with
anything except of course it will except
for a control the equal giraffe right um
actually I wonder whether thee now that
I think about it I wonder whether we
have uses a word instead um okay
stop playing here why is why is that hmm
okay we don't have the movie uh
vernacular apparently um okay the point
being made here also by Ethan was this
thing about bookmarking viewpoints I
agree that that will be useful and
hopefully that is part of the graphics
3d toolbar yeah yeah we can definitely
put that under consideration um let me
just for one second this thing about
swooping give me a name somebody must
have a name for at least one of those
weird matrix there's I think the matrix
has a but it's not called the matrix
it's whatever that thing is called that
weird you know sort of right the 60
frames in the circle to get the
slow-motion shot um yeah something like
that
anyway so something like that bullet
time we're gonna add bullet time to
product I'm talking about
look I'm just talking about something
where you have a you know there's some
definite kind of motion where you have a
3d object and you have some sort of
stylized way of looking around the 3d
object sir okay and the question is
let's say we define that we define the
path limiter in the appropriate
transformation group okay now how do we
what that turns into presumably is a
viewer that has a trigger of some kind
or it could be continuously doing it I
suppose if it's a closed path right I
mean what you would have in mind then is
in the front end either something which
is sitting there continuously animating
or it's something which has a button and
it's triggered well and and a related
thing and something that we support in
iOS but we don't support on the desktop
is the ability to do a throw yes
what does a throw mean in this context
rotate and keep going but typically with
inertia that slows down over time right
so that's when you like spin the thing
and it slows down yes so on iOS you know
you you know you press the hold and then
just kind of swipe and let go and it
just goes you know and it has inertia
but inertia that Peters out over time
let's be clear it's not in fact inertia
its friction inertia would make it keep
going well I mean the inertia it makes
it keep going for a while and the
friction makes it stopped okay um okay
but but so I mean so that's a gesture
based I mean that's one way to invoke
that your point is that there's a way to
trigger the thing that isn't you press
the button on the screen that is a
trigger right and the you know I mean
part of the reason we did that on iOS is
because gesture for doing it was obvious
yeah yeah it's it it's not that it's
like difficult to implement it's you
know ultimately I'm discoverable yeah
how do we do it yeah well I mean the
only way we could do it is something
where the I mean clearly if we have a
ribbon one of the buttons there can be
an information button which can show
little drawings of how you do the
gestures but it's a little weird anyway
something something that we yeah it's it
would be a good thing to do I mean I
know look I've been very frustrated
recently with these elongated box ratio
things and trying to turn them around
would have been very nice to just have
an automatic the thing that Auto turns
them I mean I've been I've been trying
to learn how to get and to be clear I'm
not I'm not surprised that there are
bugs around this because there there's a
history of bugs around around these guys
so you know there are a number of
exceptional things and the codes
basically to deal with things that
exceed a certain aspect ratio I see okay
I mean look the main thing that I've
been having an experience with is these
very weird objects that are very hard to
visualize very hard for humans like me
at least to sort of understand
conceptually and I'm trying to get some
sense of what you actually do and
clearly you know one thing that is
obvious about 3d it's just jigging back
and forth helps in understanding what
the thing is you know that that always
helps and being able to do that somehow
automatically being able to press a
button down in the in the way that might
be useful to have a button which you can
hold down and it jigs back and forth
while you're holding down the button
sort of like the--and the modern cell
phone cameras where you get a spot of
motion in your picture yeah I suppose I
mean yeah I suppose but I mean I haven't
yes what I have in mind here is when you
hold down the button the thing is
jigging back and forth just to give you
some yeah I know I agree with the effect
but I mean this clearly if you see that
image without any motion it's really
unclear what it is as soon as you see
that little bit of motion it becomes
much clearer what it is um so I think
that would be and presumably path is
being the this graphics 3d yes correct
so why don't we make that suggestion as
a thing as a small motion I don't even
think it matters which I mean you know
that might not even one could imagine
maybe if it's if it's a subtle effect
one could imagine doing it even just
when you select the graphic you know you
don't have to have a button for it at
all
that oh I think that would well
you mean that it just you're just a
quick little one as soon as you select
it I think a little one when you select
it will be cool I mean I I mean you know
I I agree that there's a possibility it
could drive everyone up the wall but I
think there's a possibility that it
won't and it's well as you point out
selection what about if you select
something which contains many graphics
if you select to sell to they all nod at
you at the same time I was thinking more
only if you directly selected it but but
that yes that would be highly amusing
they can each one could take a bow in
time I think if they do it well I don't
know um that's a good idea though it's
an interesting idea all right
okay um anything else we need to cover
right now right here you still think I
prepared too few agenda items no hey
good work okay do I need to send this
notebook back to Devon because I'm not
otherwise saving this yes yeah that
would be helpful okay all right see you
guys soon thanks all to folks on the
live stream see all